et que paula 1 rue des activistes et
membre du mouvement beyrouth madinaty
bonsoir aulas révèle merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france hassan diab
qui s'était donc engagée à choisir des
technocrates indépendants est ce le cas
pour ce nouveau cabinet qui a pas l'air
de plaire beaucoup aux libanais pour le
moment ce nouveau cabinet a été formée
d'une manière complètement égoïste on va
dire ils ont fait ce cabinet pour faire
plaisir à leurs propres partis ils ont
exclu certains partis et ils ont exclu
les demandes de la rue ils ont
complètement fait fi de la rue c'est
presque un défi pour nous alors vous
dites les ont ils n'ont pas du tout
écouter les demandes de la rue il
n'empêche qu'il ya quand même des
membres de ce nouveau cabinet qui sont
plutôt indépendant et réformateur ce
n'est pas votre analyse il ya tout à
jeter là dedans ce n'est pas question de
jeter ou ne pas jeter ce sont des gens
qui ont un bon parcours académique dont
la plupart à un bon bah cohade émis mais
ils appartiennent
que ce soit politiquement même s'ils
disent qu'ils sont indépendants ce n'est
pas du tout le cas
ils sont soit conseillers soient amis
soit le mari de quelqu'un qui fait
partie d'un parti politique de cette
couleur précise comment ça se fait alors
qu' il ya des manifestations qu'on
connaît un qui sont immenses un
mécontentement qui est très tenace au
liban que le nouveau gouvernement ait
pris ce risque aujourd'hui est ce que
vous vous l'expliquer ils ont ils soient
obligés vis-à-vis de la communauté
internationale et du peuple libanais de
2 d'avancé un petit peu mais je ne sais
pas ce qu'il apprend de penser que le
peuple est satisfait vous voyez bien
vous voyez vous même les images que vous
avez filmé c'est insoutenable
ils sont en train d'attaquer les gens
les manifestants d'une manière qui ne
qui n'a rien à voir avec les droits de
l'homme il ya des distances pour les
balles en caoutchouc qui sont de 35
mètres minimum ils sont en train de
tirer à trous
m nous avons plus de 500 blessés depuis
le week-end je dis nous je parle de tout
le peuple libanais que ce soit forces de
l'ordre aux manifestants
le peuple a faim le peuple n'a pas les
moyens de payer son loyer nous voyons de
plus en plus de familles descendre
habiter dans la rue ils peuvent pas
payer les écoles ce n'est pas un
gouvernement d'une seule coalition qui
va pouvoir régler cette crise est là par
exemple
oui je vous écoute vous écoutez les
aînés je vous en prie par exemple nous
pensons que le ministre de la justice
qui a affilié à un certain parti qui a
été choisie par un certain parti
comment va-t-il pouvoir juger c'est même
parti en étant c'est impossible il peut
pas les juger
ils peuvent pas du tout être comment on
va dire neutre dès qu'ils vont commencer
à faire par exemple la lutte contre la
corruption facilité contre les sa propre
famille politique ou ses propres frères
soeurs marie je sais pas mais personne
n'est dupe
quelle que soit la stratégie nous savons
très bien qu'elle ne sera qu'un
présenter leurs idées alors une partie
est effectivement de l'opposition est
clairement rester en dehors des
tractations de ce nouveau cabinet
comment le gouvernement peut désormais
composer avec cette opposition selon
vous déjà le fait qu'ils les ont mis
dehors ça veut dire qu'ils veulent pas
composer avec eux pour nous pour moi et
pour la majorité du peuple c'est un
gouvernement mort né on va voir combien
de temps ils vont durer
hassan diab a soutenu par le hezbollah
quand on sait que l'ess volaille très
mal vues par une partie de la communauté
internationale est ce qu un risque pour
vous de voir le liban est relâché par
certains pays c'est peut-être là le
point d'achoppement le point c'est
compliqué finalement négocié entre ce
gouvernement libanais et le peuple
oui parce que ce gouvernement n'aura pas
la bienveillance international vue sur
la filiation comme vous venez de le dire
ces pros et rend donc je ne vois pas
comment un gouvernement de n'importe
quel pays peut nous soutenir nous avons
besoin
d'être soutenue parce que vous voyez
bien que le peuple ne supporte plus
après 30 ans d'être gérés par ces partis
là le peuple n'arrive plus à accepter
les partis politiques ils veulent des
gens vraiment indépendant pas d je vais
je vais dire le mot des techno
mercenaires parce que cela ce sont des
indépendants en apparence mais nous
voyons tous très bien que l'oncle de
l'ain et invoqua d'un certain parti
politique
la deuxième est la femme de deux parties
d'un membre d'un parti politique c'est
vraiment pathétique voilà alors que je
trouve ces petits est ce qu'il ya des
personnalités aujourd'hui à même de se
présenter qui se sont fait connaître
auprès de ce gouvernement parce que
c'est vrai que je me fais volontairement
l'avocat du diable mais quand on cherche
à recruter évidemment on le fait dans
son entourage peut-être peut-être avec
un peu trop de facilité on prend les
gens effectivement qu'on que l'on
connaît est ce que ces personnalités là
aujourd'hui elles sont identifiées par
le pape parce qu'on sait aussi que ce
peuple est très divisée on y manque
peut-être est là toute la complication
alors nous avons eu la chance d'avoir un
bateau ni qui a été élu indépendant qui
s'appelle mais le n 4 à la ce qui
représente il s'est vraiment un
consensus dans le peuple ibère le peuple
libanais il aime beaucoup
tout le monde le respecte tous les
membres de tous les partis pas les
partis politiques le respect et nous
avons un nombre en fait ce n'est pas le
mode c'est quelqu'un dans la communauté
internationale qui s'appelle nawaf salam
qui représente vraiment les demandes de
la rue
la moitié des gens que l'on va dire
parce que le peuple on ne peut pas dire
tout le peuple
on va être obligé de dire que la moitié
du peuple le respecte et aimerait bien
qu'il soit qu'il fasse partie d'un
gouvernement vraiment indépendant
justement pas au lard et bête est ce que
ce n'est pas là tout le problème nous
dit pas tout le peuple à moitié puisque
on sait que le peuple libanais voilà une
composante extrêmement variée est ce que
ce n'est pas l'art je réitère ma
question qui est finalement le plus gros
problème à trouver un gouvernement qui
puisse satisfaire
la majorité faire taire les
mécontentements en fait je vous dis la
moitié parce que vous savez très bien
que l'autre moitié qui n'ose pas
vraiment encore s'exprimer
donc cet autre moitié de soutien souvent
ils passent et nous passe des mots ils
nous disent continuer mais il n'ose pas
descendre dans la rue vu leur
affiliation politique
et là de plus en plus on les voit
descendre avec nous ces fameuses autre
moitié
mais si on arrive à avoir un
gouvernement de gens propres et
indépendance c'est le rêve et que
j'espère que ce sera pas seulement avec
eux ce sera très bientôt une réalité
pour nous aujourd'hui clairement pas au
lard et bêtes que demande le peuple on a
compris que le peuple avait faim que le
peuple était en colère mais quelles sont
vraiment les deux trois demandes
concrètes qui ferait taire cette colère
qui semble ne jamais s'arrêter et
s'intensifier au contraire cela ne fait
que trois mois je dirais mais pour
certains ces trois mois de trop mais
c'est quand même trois mois où les gens
n'ont pas arrêté d'être dans la rue même
si la communauté internationale et la
presse internationale n'a pas présenter
cela au monde mais nous ça fait plus de
95 jours qu'on est dans la rue et nous
ne baisserons pas les bras nous
continuerons parce que nous voulons un
gouvernement indépendant
nous voulons surtout la l'indépendance
de la machine judiciaire parce que c'est
le seul moyen de régler le sort des
corrompus parce que vous savez très bien
que ça fait 30 ans que la récup
corruption gangrène le pays
rien ne peut être fait sans corrompre
quelqu'un sans donner un bakchich comme
on dit c'est c'est vraiment vous voyez à
tous les niveaux que ce soit faire un
papier dans un ministère ou à la mairie
ou bien au niveau de l'état pour acheter
de du mazout et du gaz pour le quotidien
du peuple
c'est quand même incroyable c'est c'est
pas une république bananière c'est
encore plus que ça c'est un république
agriculture bananière merci beaucoup en
tout cas par là un rêve est d'avoir été
avec nous en direct depuis le liban de
nous avoir apporté votre
analyse merci à vous